this image you see before you wasn't
drawn by a human being this was drawn by
Androids actually the technical term is
artificial intelligence Androids yeah
okay and it might just change the online
world as we know it forever and besides
the computer code music and essays these
AI systems are churning out upon command
in mere seconds it's the AI generated
artwork that you've no doubt seen
circulating around every microcosm of
the web that's given myself and my team
a moment of pause because while these AI
art generators are being used by
millions and are pretty fun to play with
many are also concerned asking the
question will they replace real life
artists well maybe they'll kill all of
you but I'm not afraid of any
over-touted washing machines and you
know what Vegeta's right we need to take
this seriously and so I held a meeting
everyone I assume you all know why I
gathered you all here today we are
challenging these AI image generating
bastards to an old-school Dragon Ball
drawing competition now I don't want to
hear any complaining this is serious
business and I will not accept weakness
on my team it's US versus the Androids
and our future might be on the light is
this understood if you set that Android
free I was told that there would be
Pizza yeah I don't understand
good furthermore Tyson slave for hours
last night tinkering with dozens of
different AI image generators to provide
the very best AI Dragon Ball art for us
to compete against how did you find that
Tyson was it tough uh yeah it was I
haven't slept in quite some time that's
what I like to hear and you're right
nothing is too difficult as long as I'm
Your Leader actually I didn't say that
at all and you still haven't paid me and
my heroic words ringing in their ears we
pressed onwards I because I'm the
fearless leader accepted two drawings
Trev because he's the best dragon ball
artist accepted three drawings to do
editor said because he died took one and
AJ took one also because he's lazy I
couldn't ask for a better team and so
with her stylist shaking screens greasy
from Pam sweat and the future of online
traditional Artistry hanging in the
balance we called forth the first AI
Challenger
AI Mark is up first which means it's
time for me to lead the way in this
contest
for saying blue Gohan and this is the
image the AI generator presented me it's
not bad but I guess I have to try and
draw a better one now something we
should answer from the outset is what AI
art is exactly simply put it is a
machine learning algorithm that is fed
tens of thousands of images from all
over the Internet of which it then
Builds an internal model of how these
images look what the images are with
metadata and the relationships between
them in other words the AI looks online
and tries to Cobble together something
based on our prompt and let me tell you
one thing we learned about AI in
producing this video is that finding
half decent AIS that can produce art in
a specific style like Dragon Ball was a
near impossibility Dolly 2 sucked stable
diffusion sucked mid-journey sucked a
lot then novel AI was actually it was
kind of okay we got a couple of decent
artworks from there that you'll see
later however all of this struggle was
finally rewarded when we found niji
Journey which is effectively a weeb fork
of big Journey trained on a bunch of
anime images and from ninjis respond to
this Gohan I'm currently working on
which looks pretty damn good that is
until you look at it for longer than two
seconds while this might be the most on
model piece we'll be correcting today
this might be the best time to talk
about the most upfront flaw with most AI
art that it only looks good at a glance
so much of even the best AI Art Online
looks pretty good when you first take a
grinder but the second you dedicate even
a moment of time to look at is in finer
details it sort of falls apart random
artifacts in the image inconsistencies
that make no sense broken an anime that
I kid you not confused me to such an
extent that I struggle to understand
what exactly Gohan was doing with his
arm was he fixing his wristband or was
he holding his shoulder it's honestly a
coin toss funnily enough though and
you'll see this in Later drawings too
these Androids hate drawing hands and
I'll tell you why because artists around
the world hate drawing hands and its
data is sourced from real life artists
and speaking of real life artists I
decided to try and style this Gohan in a
classic Dragon Ball Z masahiroshima Nuki
style and in the effects was enjoyable
and in the end I actually ended up
having a lot of fun working on this
however little did I know that this
would be the easiest of the two drawings
that I would work on in this video but
yeah here's a quick before and after I
think it looks much better but you can
let us know in the comments who you
thought defeated the Android did I win
this round or does it go to the washing
machine you decide alright so which
Android is up next
a-i-a-j which means next up the draw is
real life AJ and he'll be correcting
this stylized Videl holding a frankly
enormous Burger as we alluded to Prior
this image comes from novel AI which let
me tell you will relentlessly produce
lewd artwork unless you consistently and
deliberately beg it not to and not
entirely unlike real life AJ to be
honest so it's fitting similar to the
last image there are some interesting
flaws we got some floaty hair squiggly
mouth eyelashes in her eye and a giant
burger held anyway that fills me with
more anger than I am capable of
expressing in words how dare you
inferiorating Burger holding technique
aside the biggest problem here is that
we asked it for the style of Dragon Ball
and this is obviously not that while
novel AI wasn't trained much on Dragon
Ball it was clearly trained on loads of
x-rated Twitter and Tumblr posts and
with that knowledge this is probably a
good time to talk about the quote
capability of AI art novel AI is largely
incapable of generating things that look
like Dragon Ball solely because it
hasn't been fed Dragon Ball styled
images or at least not enough of them
that is to say that these airchen models
are not creative if you were to feed
them 1 000 Renaissance error paintings
they are never ever ever ever going to
create neoclassical error art or
Romantic Era art or even Modern Art an
AI music generator is never going to be
fed 1940s rhythm and blues and then
create rock and roll because there is
quite literally not a creative element
in place here to speak of it is simply
data that is input processed and then
similar data output based on the prompt
in other words you can only get out what
you put in and with this image AJ took
the task not only fixing the structural
issues of Videl but also adapted it to
the Dragon Ball style all the while
giving it its own personal Flair which
as we mentioned is something that AI is
incapable of doing and we think the
results speak for themselves
let us know who you thought won this
round
next up it's a big one and it's AI Trev
and he's actually producing this
dramatic obvious sort of janky looking
Broly I hope you're ready for this one
Trev hold nothing back I think well
perhaps more visually striking than the
last two this AI generated Broly artwork
demonstrates more obvious problems than
we've otherwise seen big hand shadownet
baz fur is screwed up and there's a
random floating green orbs in the middle
of this I don't understand why is that
there and that's ignoring the dude's
whole face situation so yeah godspeed
Trev like I said AI art is just data in
data outright and you can see first-hand
examples of that on Tick Tock with their
recent trend of the anime filter I
uploaded a video onto my Tick Tock where
I basically use Vegeta and it turned him
into an anime girl every single time
specifically because the AI was fed
anime girls but you might be asking
yourself so why well I'm willing to
wager that there's someone out there or
perhaps even a few of you that are
getting a strange sense of deja vu
looking at this AI Broly as it looks
very very similar to a lot of art both
official or otherwise for many of these
images you can almost directly make out
the chunk of images that they were
trained on and as a result so many of
the ai's art Generations come out very
much looking like certain fan artists
Dragon Ball Heroes art and legends are
to name but a few and perhaps it doesn't
take much to see what I'm getting at by
bringing this up there's an ethical
discussion to be had here about the
image sources none of these are taken
with consent whether they be from
official sources fan art or what have
you they're all simply scraped from the
internet and fed into this machine this
machine that can output quote art based
on Stolen work that can be technically
sold marketed or posted as though it was
unique we could literally generate some
AI Dragon Ball art right now made out of
pre-existing fan art and sell it as our
own and that's not even speculation by
the way that's literally covered in
novel ai's very own terms of service and
to me at least that seems really
unethical with that said I think what
Trev has done here by adding model
correctness fixing flaws and
implementing his own effects work has
ended up creating a truly impressive
final piece check out that before and
after I mean come on it's amazing work
and I hope you use that Broly as a good
warm-up trip because AI Trev is up again
next and produced a really striking
Paradox okay now I say striking but what
I really mean is holy crap what's wrong
with his broken back arm that devolves
into a body horror fist completely
broken face weird hair pastry roll armor
and so on like oddly enough I can tell
that this is Bardock and the composition
is striking but that's about where the
compliments with this one stop it's an
absolute disaster piece to say the least
now a popular argument used in favor of
air using stolen art to learn is that
that's precisely how humans themselves
learn they observe other art learn from
it then produce similar art and this
gives rise to Natural evolutions of art
like Blues eventually giving rise to the
likes of rock and roll as I mentioned
prior and I think the best argument we
have against that line of thinking is
quite simply that there is no create
native element to speak of in AI it by
Design cannot innovate based on what is
input and even further than that there
are many fundamental flaws with this
argument post for one it sort of
personifies a literal computer program
nothing about its set of ones and zeros
is learning or observing anything in a
human sense and even aside from that we
are sidestepping the fundamental issue
with the way AI art is trained that is
that it is fed droves of images with a
complete disregard for a lack of
copyright compensation permission and so
on and each model is taking literally
hundreds of thousands of human hours
worked yoinking it then with no regard
for the original artist generating
images from them images that will either
be sold for profit or used to advertise
their AI website by showing derivative
work of the very artists they stole from
and as you can see here with trev's
illustration of Bardock particularly
when we do a before and after you can
see that there's something significant
gained when you apply the ability of a
professionally trained artist to A work
like this that you otherwise cannot
generate on a computer this pose with
Bardock simply doesn't exist online and
so naturally because these Androids
cannot create something specific and
accurate we get something like this
instead of something like what Trev made
but okay that's enough from Trev for now
next up in the arena of artistic
gladiatorial combat is
AI editor sound destroying this Bulma
eating or vomiting I can't tell and
we're back in novel AI land with this
Bulma and you know what she's cute lord
Only Knows whose lovely artwork it quote
borrowed to arrive at this result but
it's still cute barring you know the
dead eyes eyelashes and uh oh yeah the
noodles she's spewing from her mouth
onto the floor I think she's supposed to
be eating them but whatever the case
this is not how you eat noodles and
editor-san is on the case to right this
wrong in addition to correcting this
affront to humanity editor San has
decided to take this a different
direction entirely by trying to emulate
the more modern Toriyama style and
really that's a convenient segue to the
topic of specificity and creativity with
regards to artificial intelligence many
of you at this point might rightfully be
thinking that since stealing images from
artists without permission copyright
acquisition or compensation is bad we
ought to train a better AI model with
only legally acquired or public domain
images right I mean that sounds like a
good idea and most importantly an
ethical course to steer our AI ship well
here's where we run into another huge
problem with AI art presently not only
does it lack the ability to make a
creative decision to adapt this art with
its own twist on an established style it
also struggles deeply with specificity
meaning even the best AI art models
presently are for lack of a better term
throwing paint against the wall and
seeing what sticks ask it to make an
image of unit 0-1 from Evangelion
walking a giant Corgi in the city and
you will get well a lot of things that
aren't that and being able to produce
what's being specifically requested or
being looked for is vitally important I
don't know if any of you have ever done
art for a client before but specificity
is King to delivering an actual product
worth paying for details big and small
precise and minute changes to clothes
Expressions backgrounds composite and so
on all things that are absolutely vital
to delivering a result that not only
pleases the client who's paying you
money but it's the key to what makes it
Style just that a specific style AI art
is just completely and wholly incapable
of that right now and unfortunately that
flaw with AI is with the extremely vast
array of stolen art it uses to train
itself how much do you think that
problem will be exacerbated if it
decreases its pool of images to train
Itself by
99.98 only using legitimately acquired
or open domain art the answer not too
well to say the least but as you can see
with editor Sans work he was able to
apply years of practice and
understanding of not just the subject
but the specific demands of the pose to
construct the anatomy and create the
desired mood for this piece to pop and
the end result honestly looks
aesthetically pleasing to me almost like
something you'd see from a 90s noodles
commercial however now it's time for me
to face my Everest and what I stand
against is pretty intimidating you me
hot as you can
are we clear
Crystal
this was hard and to be honest through
the struggle stopping and starting and a
lot of help from all the artists in this
video I'm pretty pleased with how this
one turned out and I think with this one
because of that effort and passion
highlights why this one works as well as
it does because there are a significant
amount of creative Liberties taken with
it to create this AI Vegeta The Prompt
was Vegeta striking a dynamic pose and
using that as my prompt I decided to not
only correct the mistakes made by this
AI but change the pose to something more
suited to Vegeta and incorporate some
other bells and whistles you'll be happy
to say I'm sure in other words we're
going full Super Vegeta with this one
and so now you might be asking what
about using AI art as an inspiration for
artists that that's a use case right
well I mean you could I just don't think
it'd be anything worth taking
inspiration from largely speaking and
I'm sure a lot of artists might actually
agree with me here let me explain why I
think this when an artist is looking at
another person's work for reference and
inspiration they aren't just looking at
the subject to copy but are instead
looking for a specific approach and
perspective an execution of a pose or
angle the composition of the image the
stylistic quirks of their work the use
of value in this piece to draw the eye
in and a million other elements that are
all drawn from that particular human set
of skills sensibilities and life
experiences what makes someone an artist
make a decision in how they draw isn't
necessarily down to some dogmatic widely
used and accepted practice often times
but is also informed by that artist's
lived experiences in other words great
artwork can tell you something about the
artists themselves these are all things
that are born from a single source and
intrinsically cannot be derived from AI
art most of us love how certain scenes
like this look but a more casual
Observer might not understand why this
looks as great as it does or why so many
agree as we've discussed in detail now
ai art is an amalgamation there is no
stylistic quirk to study you will never
get a yuya Takahashi from an AI
generated image unless you feed it a
bunch of his work at which point you're
better off just looking at the originals
anyway and honestly the now famous
Dragon Ball animator yuya Takahashi is a
great case study for this this is an
individual who grew up with classic
Dragon Ball Z was inspired by it and
that inspiration eventually gave rise to
his own style that is now world famous
in Dragon Ball super people love his
artwork it's clearly inspired by some
that was once before but is also
something entirely new and in that same
way I decided to ignore this piece
largely and Implement artwork that
resonated with me what I felt like
drawing using effects work and shading
that I felt at work and reminded me of
one of my favorite artists yuya
takahashi's work while also implementing
some of my own stylistic Works into the
mix creating a brand new piece and
hopefully you think it looks cool which
brings us thankfully to our last drawing
of the video and it comes by way of AI
trash here we have I think Gohan riding
a bike and believe it or not this was
the best of the bunch that we generated
for this particular image complete with
cousin thing from The Adams Family on
the left handlebar in this video we've
taken a rather negative albeit
principled approach against AI generated
art but that's also not to say that AI
art has no place at all far from it it's
clearly already become this incredible
tool that's taken the Internet by storm
and so if nothing else I posit that it
has a true use and that purpose is
larger than one everyone at this point
has largely seen it is an exceptionally
fun toy to experiment with we've
established that using it for any form
of profit or claim is inherently immoral
as it is and we've also covered that it
lacks the depth and specificity to
replace actual illustrators concept
artists and the like in any real Prof
professional setting but look across the
internet and you'll also see what
99.99999 of the people that have been
using it have been doing and you will
see exactly how it shines it is a very
fun pretty powerful toy you're certainly
not going to get the same level of craft
thought and creativity that you would
otherwise get from a real life artist
after commissioning them but you know
what you can do generate an image of
Adele eating a burger the wrong way in
10 seconds you can generate an image of
Shrek playing basketball on the moon an
image of Gohan riding a sick motorcycle
along a dirt road with a new outfit and
when you think about it that's an
exceptionally fun tool to have at our
disposal to play with the near instant
ability to bring silly ideas to life
even if they are usually not
particularly well done is not only a
novel experience but something I'm sure
Millions who aren't artistically
inclined can experiment with for fun it
opens up a whole new world to them and I
think that is a perfectly reasonable
purpose for something like this is it
really necessary to insist that AI art
must strive to be more do we need the
air to become a perfectly moral
omnipotently skilled artist capable of
generating all art in the world must
this Innovation be used in a way that
seeks profit perhaps this is the
inevitable end result that is pretty
much the case with all other
technological advancements of modern
times but this is different this one
doesn't aim to keep us from having to
dig a painstaking hole in the ground to
fit a fence in this doesn't aim to save
us the effort of driving 20 miles down
the road to buy a screwdriver its
expressed goal is to give us the same
art we had before but without having to
pay an artist to get it though you
better believe you'll have to pay the AI
art company though but with that said
creativity is an inherently sentient
trait humans have been making art since
they could hold tools it is a beautiful
and personal expression of each
individual a sum of a thousand lifetimes
of inspiration and lived experience with
each giant of their respective era
acting as the foothold for which the
next great constant upon in an ethical
manner it is not something worth
automating and so yeah I'm fine with it
being a toy because you know what
sometimes I just want to quickly see
what Conan O'Brien in a banana suit
looks like I mean who doesn't
[Music]